hello and welcome to the new world
reveal source for everything anime and
manga and today we are back with hunter
hunter quite specifically to discuss one
of the many profound mysteries that have
been left lingering by series author
yoshihiro togashi and a lot of these
lingering mysteries can range from
mildly intriguing to potentially world
shaking to of course greatly frustrating
because the likelihood of ever being fed
the answers is next to none because the
thing to remember about hunter hunter is
that even when the series was being
published regularly togashi very
purposely leaves certain characters
plots or concepts
completely unfinished and whether that's
because he prefers ambiguity or he just
gets bored of writing certain things
is entirely up for debate whatever the
case happens to be we are here to
explore what we know about the concept
of the floor masters of heaven's arena
as well as the battle olympia tournament
quite possibly one of the most exciting
global events in hunter hunter that we
never came close and will never come
close to witnessing and to begin our
mysterious exploration we're going to
have a quick round of crallow or kroll
no
a very simple minigame the rules of
which are as follows mr sneaky phantom
man has decided to hide himself in one
of these three jars and it is going to
be your job to guess which gel crawler
is lurking in should you guess
incorrectly then your punishment will be
to subscribe to the new world review
thus resulting in consistent injections
of hunter culture administered straight
into your youtube feed and if you are
correct then you will be invited to join
the phantom troupe
maybe but probably not so which jar will
it be
a b or the other one please do make your
choice now and we shall reveal the
answer in
three two one and bam that sneaky
crowler was in jar b
so if you chose a orc then you know
things to do and please do say hi in the
comments below if you are a new member
of the channel
welcome sticking with krollo though he
leads quite nicely into this mystery
because anime fans may or may not be
aware of this but mr lucille fur is
actually a cannon floor master of
heaven's arena or at least he was his
status is
kind of vague these days but we will get
to that the first thing we need to do is
establish
exactly what a floor master is within
the heavens arena facility the top 21
floors are reserved for one combatant
each a person who has gone through the
grueling progression of flaws 1 through
floor 229
although i will say that in the series
most of that journey didn't seem like a
particular challenge for gone and killer
but you need to remember that gon and
kilauea
are gone and kilauea but even your above
average naturally talented martial
artist like say sushi is going to have a
tough task ahead with that said zushi
was already deliberately handicapped by
wing not allowing him to use
ren but to also be fair that is a very
cheesy win condition against non-nine
users and that is something we should
also address despite heaven's arena
acting as a sort of global combat mecca
it would appear that nen
users are incredibly uncommon until we
reach the 200th floor at which point you
were just a few short steps away from
being eligible to challenge a floor
master in a match
in order to do this a combatant must win
10 matches on the 200th floor which
gives them the right to challenge a
floor master of their choosing or
actually i'm not entirely sure if that's
the case
it's kind of vague like most things in
the series in both the anime and the
manga it just says that it gives the
contestant the ability to challenge a
floor master so that might be assigned
at random
or in order of whichever master is on
the lowest floor something like that
in any case if you defeat one then the
successful challenger will be awarded
the title and status of floor master
an illustrious position in the eyes of
the general public because it makes you
look like you're one of the 21 strongest
fighters in the world however within the
greater context of hunter hunter the
strength of the floor masters is
incredibly questionable in comparison to
that of professional hunters
world-renowned criminals or even strange
anthropomorphic ants
all of which really does make heaven's
arena look like a bit of a child's
playground in retrospect which is why i
suppose
our two child protagonists used it as
sort of a kindergarten nen course
with that said beyond the 200th floor is
a mixed bag of men users some of which
are complete jokes whilst others are to
be taken incredibly seriously and in
fact the only canon floor masters that
we know of in hunter hunter fall into
that latter category
the first of which is someone that we're
all quite uncomfortably familiar with
being mr hisoka
bihi clown magician or both we were
actually lucky enough to witness the
fight that allowed him to challenge a
floor master which was his bout against
gone and after defeating a child with a
fishing rod hisoka eventually invoked
his own invitation and evidently
defeated whichever floor master he faced
thus acquiring the title for himself
as we see in manga events beyond the
anime and
oh yeah it might be a little late to
flag this but yes this video will
contain manga spoilers because i mean
look the anime ended seven years ago now
and it's my sad duty to inform you that
it won't be coming back anytime soon
perhaps at all but all of that said
hisoka's floor master status was real to
us
alongside another being crawler
unfortunately crowler's journey is far
more unknown in fact it's completely
unknown in the manga all that is
stipulated is that hisoka was the one
who arranged the match and it was his
very first as a floor master meanwhile
crawler
already held this title which is one of
those really interesting contradictions
that pops up in time to time from hunter
hunter you know the fact that crollo can
be a global celebrity and participate in
televised combat and yet also be one of
the most highly sought-after criminals
in the world like you'd think that the
very fact that he's in heaven's arena
would cause a national scale operation
to try and apprehend him but no he can
just
do whatever with all that said it's also
entirely possible that crowler only
became a floor master for the purpose of
fighting against hisoka in heaven's
arena that location was the key factor
in crollo's strategy for defeating the
mad clown thing and it simply would not
have worked on any other battlefield and
the more i think about it the more
likely it is that becoming a floor
master was just yet another small piece
in crollo's master plan which i think
doesn't say particularly great things
about heaven's arena you know the fact
that if required a powerful and
experienced end user can rather simply
reach its pinnacle with very minimal
effort because i guess the thing is that
our only two cannon floor masters are
crolo and hisoka but even so that is
incredibly misrepresentative of floor
masters in general and we do actually
have something of a rough gauge of their
average level which is embodied within
castro remember
castro probably not because in
retrospect he is incredibly irrelevant
and the fact that there were two of him
only doubles his forgettability all of
which is to say that castro is the
closest possible comparison we have to
your general floor master in fact
castro's 200th floor record was
technically better than hisoka's because
he had nine wins and one loss as opposed
to hisoka's eight wins and three
losses and it should be noted that all
of hisoka's losses were forfeits against
castro because hisoka wanted him to
continue to grow and become much more of
a juicy opponent to eventually kill you
know
the standard hisoka stuff but catching
hisoka's attention is not an easy thing
to do like during the election arc he
was scoffing at almost every
professional hunter by the zodiacs so
castro look in reality he's not all that
bad however with that said he was still
an amateur nen user at best and he fell
victim to very basic nen shenaniganori
from hisoka and as underwhelming as it
may be i do think that's what you can
expect to find in the other floor
masters as well castro was considered to
be an above average talent with a clear
path to the top he just needed one more
victory to challenge a floor master and
then he was potentially one of them but
in the end he was a whole lot of nothing
i mean comparatively that is which is
always the tricky thing about heaven's
arena it produces a false impression of
the world because as far as we know
hunters and
like legitimately skilled men users
don't actually participate there because
why would they need to hunters make
enough money for the rewards of heaven's
arena to just be a joke and in addition
to that it would risk putting their
abilities on full display but any other
nenus are watching to dissect to the
truly powerful of hunter hunter it
really is only good for one thing
which is training gifted children and
with that in mind i do always find it
funny that both gone and kilauea had
such a disappointed reaction to finding
out that battle olympia was the end goal
of heaven's arena because compared to
their goals in life it just sounded
wildly underwhelming and speaking of
wildly underwhelming you might be
wondering why i haven't mentioned
something very integral to this
discussion which is one of the films
hunter hunter the last mission now i
don't talk about these films a lot and
there's good reason for that because
they're not very good but in this
particular film
all 21 floor masters are revealed to us
and we even see the beginnings of the
battle olympia tournament
and the reason why we see all of this is
because it's
not canon a lot of people argue that it
is because there's never been an
official statement made but it doesn't
really fit continuity wise and a lot of
the ideas and characters we're exposed
to
they're just better off forgotten don't
ever get me started about on but also
being better off forgotten are the floor
masters in the film these guys are as
good as cannon fodder in fact there's a
fairly hilarious moment where like 19 of
the 21 floor masters they're all in the
same room and
each and every one of them are defeated
fairly instantaneously by
one man and look i know that floor
masters are not all that great in the
grand scheme of hunter hunter but they
are bound to be
much much better than they're
represented here then possessed by on a
concept that once again i'm not going to
get into here
half of them are then beaten by
pre-chimera ant gone and kilauea whilst
another half are casually taken care of
by karapika it's all a bit sad really
and i have a very hard time believing
that chairman netro would bother
presiding over this pack of nobodies
especially since the hunter association
shows no interest in this arena like i
said beyond training their gifted
children in the film hisoka also assigns
his famed point score rating to one of
the main antagonists the same main
antagonist who instantly defeated 19 of
the four masters at once and he soaker
rates him at a mighty
65 points out of 100 which isn't too bad
for him it's more than most professional
hunters during the election arc got but
it does go on to further minimize these
non-canon floor masters because 65 is
still
pretty abysmal oh and also fun fact in
the film zushi has become a floor master
which is very impressive given that it
doesn't take place too long after the
events of heaven's arena however it also
doesn't do a lot of favors for the
perceived status of a floor master if it
is a title that can be attained so
easily by someone like zushi it doesn't
matter though like i said it's not canon
in other non-canon events the floor
masters were also very briefly shown in
the 1999 anime it's a very quick collage
of random figures which is very
interesting because they are never shown
in the manga or the 2011 anime not even
in like vague silhouettes and i find
this interesting because it shows what
was in the minds of the anime crafts
people when constructing the scene
obviously the 1999 adaptation takes a
lot of liberties some of which are fun
and some of which
well they're there but the fact that
they felt comfortable enough to show the
floor masters in a fair amount of detail
likely shows how confident they were
that togashi would never really revisit
the concept
maybe he was a bit burned out on
tournament writing after yu hakusho but
in many ways i'm very glad that he
didn't elect to pursue these ideas in
the end floor masters and heaven's arena
as a whole just were not relevant to any
of our main characters their pursuits or
the world at large
it almost feels like togashi did this
very purposely a lot of the time you can
say and i have said this many times
before that togashi starts writing an
idea he's excited about and then
abandons it in favor of whatever he
becomes excited about midway through and
in this case you could almost take it as
an author's commentary on the concept of
tournament arcs in general you know
togashi sets up this
intricate complex facility with a whole
ranking system and a big promised
showdown at the end
after which point his protagonists
become noticeably uninterested in
heaven's arena seeing it as completely
unnecessary to their own stories perhaps
even going on to express the idea that
tournament arcs don't actually do a
whole lot for characters in fact a lot
of the time they actively store
progression in favor of creating
consistent and hopefully dramatically
fueled action
leading to a guaranteed climax in the
final battle so as intriguing as it may
have been to examine floor masters and
battle olympia in a bit more depth in
the end i do think that togashi may have
created them for more of a parody-style
purpose
something to acknowledge that hunt
hunter will not be following that
particular shonen trope because
well we've got better things to do don't
we things like spending an entire
chapter laying out
in painful detail how various types of
auctions work
because that's just hunter hunter and
that's one of the big reasons why it
stands apart as a completely unique
experience but for more unique
experiences do check out this video this
one right here more hunt unto goodness
coming your way so i look forward to
seeing you there
you